before we get to our special new year's
day show we want to get a check of this
morning's headlines from our cbs news
broadcast center elise preston joins us
with the very latest elise
thanks dana and good new year's day to
everyone well 2022 is our third calendar
year of dealing with the coronavirus
pandemic here in new york city there
were only about 15 000 revelers in times
square to see the bond drop to ring in
the new year it comes as covet cases
here have skyrocketed in recent weeks at
the vatican this morning crowds were
limited as pope francis conducted a new
year's day mass on friday the pope
canceled his traditional new year's eve
visit to the nativity scene in saint
peter's square to discourage large
crowds from forming nationwide in the
u.s the average number of new cases has
nearly quadrupled since december 1st
that's when the omicron variant was
first detected in the united states
so with the omicron tsunami i think
we've been calling it new jersey's
governor is in a course of officials
likening the skyrocketing rise of
omicron varying cases with extreme
weather conditions 15 states are seeing
record new case counts nationally more
than two million coronavirus cases were
reported in one week and we also know
that this is likely an undercount as
many residents testing positive through
at home antigen tests aren't necessarily
reporting those cases getting a test at
all has resulted in long waits in like
two hours especially if you're either
whether you're by yourself or if you're
in a car full of kids in washington d.c
the line stretched for blocks to get a
free rapid covet 19 home test kit on new
year's eve but celebrating has been cut
short in some places san francisco and
atlanta canceled public events and
today's rose parade won't have this
kaiser permanente float because 20 front
line medical workers said to be on it
were moved to treat patients our
hospitals right now are roughly the same
numbers they were on the worst day of
last winter's surge and as holiday
vacations wrap up so many airline
workers testing positive continue to
disrupt flights hopefully we can make
this one it's coming up delayed again
again
more than 1500 flights were canceled
friday meanwhile the state department is
warning people traveling abroad may face
unexpected challenges while trying to
return to the u.s and should make
contingency plans and consider this when
making a new year's resolution if we
aren't all taking this seriously we're
going to be in the same rotation for a
really long time
early indications from south africa
where omicron first emerged may offer a
bit of hope the rate of cases is
declining just weeks after it first
appeared health officials here have
indicated that could be the situation
here